There was a woman who said her husband on fire killed him for raping her seven
year old daughter.
She found him murder at him
and yes,
he deserves death penalty.
Nope.
If you support the death penalty,
please take the lights at the left.
If you do not support the death penalty,
take the light to the right.
Okay.
First statement,
step forward.
If you agree,
if you do not agree,
if it is not true for you,
stay exactly where you are.
Having a death penalty deters people from committing crimes.
I don't know that any regular human,
the average human,
which is who we're speaking about,
would risk their life when,
when that survival instinct is so incredibly ingrained and so strong,
that's the foundation of my entire argument.
The reason why I stay on the left hand side,
not because I feel that capital punishment should be Honda [inaudible] to
everyone that commits a crime.
No,
I'm talking about the idea that I,
my opinion,
capital punishment as a deterrent.
It influences the way people behave.
Look at Michigan,
Michigan abolished capital punishment,
1858 exactly.
Look at the crime rate Msq Retina.
Ridiculous.
So let me ask you guys,
your child grabs a vase purposely.
You see them grab the vase,
smash it on the ground,
look,
you dead in the eye or they just everything my punishment.
Yes,
of course.
If are they aware of their actions?
They're four years old.
Exactly.
They looked you right.
So I know what they did.
They know what they're doing wrong.
It's like a challenge.
You know,
they're going to continue to do the same thing over and over and they're going
to
punishing that child.
You spoke to that child.
People though might not have all the information in the way that a four year old
doesn't have all the information
disagree with.
I really don't remember.
Anytime someone was like,
you know,
I'm really want to kill someone,
but that death penalty man,
oh no,
it just doesn't make sense to me that that's an deterrent.
Um,
if anything,
uh,
a human connection to someone like to themselves or their family or someone they
care about has been the biggest deterrent in my idea.
Of course
anyone can be rehabilitated back into society.
Absolutely.
Here's the thing.
I think this is probably the most hippie part about my whole thinking is that
that unending optimism for people that I know better than to give up on someone.
Okay.
I agreed with the first half of the sentence,
but not the second,
and then I think anybody can be rehabilitated.
That doesn't mean that they're going back into society.
There are options for somebody to live a full,
complete life and not be a danger to society.
You also have to look at it with child molestation cases.
I mean,
how are you going to send someone that did the crime like that and so heinous
and it's happened many times where they released his people constantly and
they're still doing the same.
No matter how much you try to rebill it,
rehabilitate someone,
they also have to want to be rehabilitated in order to,
in order for it.
That's the thing we're assuming people don't want to be rehabilitated.
That's my whole point is that if you can believe some people don't want to be
rehabilitated though,
then you'd have to also believe the possibility that they could redeem
themselves and do something amazing after that rehabilitation happened.
For those people that that are just like past rehabilitation or they are
deserving of death,
is that what we've come to?
It really,
it really depends on,
again,
circumstances,
the circumstances,
of course,
this crime,
that's where we're getting to like where are we to stay,
who's deserving or not.
We need to actually know their entire store and who they are as a person,
their upbringing,
what got them into that situation,
their mental stability.
All of those things can be taken more into consideration,
but that goes to say that once you read their book that you're going to be
empathetic and it's clear that they've taken
no,
when families have lost and kids do too
tire most important time to have empathy.
Yes.
That's the whole point is when families have gone through that to understand
what the family's going through on top of what the person went through it.
Okay.
Everyone deserves a second chance.
Personally,
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think everybody deserves a second chance,
but I do believe that there are people who do deserve it.
So it just depends.
Again,
like I was mentioning earlier,
it depends on what kind of crime the committee,
if it's,
if they killed somebody,
I don't believe that they deserve a second chance.
But if they is like a lesser crime,
like they're stealing something from the store,
like candy or something like that or,
or a TV or a bike,
I do believe that they deserve a second chance.
Here's the thing for me,
this is why it gets hypocritical to me in this kind of discussion where we all
think about the other person of the victim or something like that in terms of
second chances.
But the whole biggest idea we,
we really confront this idea is if it was us,
where would I want a second chance?
If I knew I messed up on something,
however heinous or big it was,
or however small it was,
I want that second chance for me.
And if for at least my family and friends,
that's the least I want.
So that's why I know it applies to everyone.
I think it depends on what the second chance is.
That doesn't mean that there is absolute reentry into society.
And a second chance often means giving someone their life.
Just say a horrendous crime there.
I had someone raped in burns the one alive.
It's a horrendous crime to just let them out of society.
That's too much of a second chance.
But from what?
Within the confines of prison for such a heinous act that you do get a little
bit more.
Only one.
Yeah.
Um,
just want to go back to statement.
people deserve chances.
Um,
does every single person deserves a second chance?
In my opinion,
no.
Because maybe what the crime that they committed then you're talking about.
I would love to have the chance to have a second chance.
There's a difference between I would love to have it and I deserve it.
I think I'm a little confused about where it is that this line is drawn because
that makes the difference between a second chance between life and death,
between consideration and no consideration.
Yeah,
I think it,
I think it does start with Eh,
the obviously the crime that you commit.
There's a difference between intentionally an annotation.
Okay.
So if I put a pillow over a woman's face versus if I chuck her up,
you're still
life.
That is the height of
premed.
If it was calculated,
I don't think you deserve a second chance.
And in my opinion for a crime like that.
No,
I don't care.
I'm newer Morris.
I've no mercy for anyone he kills.
I know.
Okay.
There was,
um,
I spoke about this the other day.
There was a woman who said her husband on fire killed him for raping her seven
year old daughter.
She found him murdered him.
That was not self defense.
It was premeditated.
Yes.
And yes,
she deserves the and yesterday deserves death penalty.
It is.
She can listen.
She,
she can go through the legal pro.
I don't care how much it hurts you.
I understand that.
I understand it.
But you still need to go through the legal process like everybody else.
You don't take it into your own hands to go and to go in.
Yeah.
I don't see like it's global justice,
like you're doing something for the world,
like you are moving a threat,
but that woman was doing some global justice if I ever heard it.
That was not her right to do though.
It,
that's not how it works.
A jury of your peers that we as citizens,
we as the constituency,
we have that right then what?
Because we have numbers because we have
penalty is a state a state sanctioned homicide.
It's still,
it still is a homicide,
but it is decided by multiple people at that point.
I think we need to go above the legal system in this dialogue because it was
legal to have.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
We have to go beyond this and that was awesome.
Then what we're talking about.
If someone genuinely apologizes for a crime,
their punishment should be reduced.
MMM.
Um,
the thing is like,
of course,
it's the hardest part of this concept.
This idea is how do you judge someone's genuine authenticity and in their
apologetic ness,
right?
I specifically remember a case,
uh,
Stanley Williams,
this guy,
I'm really convinced me that he was apologetic for his crime.
And the thing was he believed he didn't commit the crime.
He was innocent of the crime,
but he was still apologetic for his past crimes that he had done in his life and
the things that he did get convicted for.
So,
um,
when I saw that he'd made a children's book about preventing other kids from
actually ending up where he ended up as a gang member and leader of the crips,
I believe,
um,
that was enough for me where he's actually going out of his way to prevent
future crime from happening for other people.
I'm like,
all right,
I accept your apology,
man.
I,
except that big time,
man.
There's no way of validating apology.
I mean like,
how do you know if they're apologizing?
They're lying.
You know,
that was a lot.
I mean,
there are people who seem so genuine and Yup.
Behind,
you know,
behind their eyes.
Yeah.
Are you doing not useful?
Let's just say a gang on gang violence.
Just a dad,
a gang member did a hit on a house of a leading gate opposing gang member in
their family and kids just say,
well,
shooting,
he killed three people.
Just say eventually he did apologize.
It doesn't matter.
He's still killed someone and he should still serve a life sentence for that.
What if this person did so much to redeem themselves or account for that and
actually show their genuine apologetic that's behind it?
I do not set the whole thing.
I don't care.
Is that debate?
They committed murder.
They get,
they get like in prison,
no death penalty.
They get white and so they became Mother Teresa after this.
Nope.
No,
I've been president.
They get naked to see their life behind bars.
One thing it's important to consider the,
the dues stress that this gentleman is under.
He's in a gang lifestyle and a gang environment where he's gonna get his ass
beat if he does not go make this hit.
Even in military crimes.
Yup.
Like in World War Two all of those people that followed orders,
yes,
they were guilty of those crimes.
There are people who will post.
There are people who try to,
within Hitler's own group,
tried to kill Hitler.
You still at the individual chose to do an action.
You can't count on somebody else to have courage and the capacity that you do.
You can't count on somebody to be as intelligent or as brave as you are.
If we,
if we just allow someone just to skirt by like that,
we're giving a bad example to everybody else in society and they're going to
think that they could just repeat the same thing and they're going to get over.
Wait,
what's that?
I believe that anyone can forgive anyone given enough time.
I just want to sit on that side.
I can do that.
Yes.
So right here,
this time,
I mean,
once I wrote a story about a mother that forgave the killer of our child,
I'm like,
okay,
okay.
I believe in it.
I believe anything is possible.
Now,
uh,
imagine your mother for a second.
Right?
Okay.
If someone were to kill your mother,
would you be able to forgive that person?
No.
Eventually.
Eventually it'd hard question was with
time.
Anyone could.
I'm going to say,
I'm going to say yes with the shirt.
With time,
unless you've really experienced something like that,
you won't know yourself really.
You,
you only know what you feel right now.
But unless you were in that motion where it did happen,
that,
that mentality,
you don't,
you don't know where to traumatize people with that question.
Oh,
hello.
First of all,
guys,
for asking a question about your mother.
I applaud you for even giving consideration to forgive that person and for
myself personally.
Um,
if someone like that that happened,
my mom,
I was fighting so hard for myself to forgive that person who committed that act,
knowing that he has destroyed my life,
Alice's destroy our family's lives,
I think I would eventually forgive.
But I know there's people out there who would always hold a grudge.
I think justify someone killing my mother.
I mean,
I can't,
I don't,
I can't see myself forgiving someone like that
hurting.
Great concept about it immediately for giving someone and finding the reasons to
forgive them later like that.
That actually helped me find peace of mind knowing that that's the guaranteed
like where I should end up anyway.
You know?
So back to this concept of our own mothers.
Okay.
If my mother were to commit murder,
I would vouch for her to receive capital punishment.
Yeah.
I,
I can't,
you know,
I can't sit here and be a hypocrite.
Oh.
And say,
and I'm for capital punishment,
if my own mother would to commit a crime is so heinous.
Yeah.
I would before even for her,
the law,
the lies to everybody.
One,
even my own mother.
Yeah.
If law enforcement abides by how still by,
by the laws of US citizens have to buy below.
Yeah.
Mom said too,
this is a very troubling thing for me that anybody walked up to these chairs
because one,
it's something that I questioned morally and emotionally about our society that
we're not already crying or feeling some kind of feeling about our own mother
being on death row because now we can easily imagine if we take it one more step
further,
that every single person on death row is somebody's mother or father or sister
or brother.
We we can't escape.
That will be sad,
but at the same time,
they committed a crime and they have to pay for it.
That's it for the death penalty though.
Why it had to be the jet it,
why would I be for the most to me in the first place on other crimes,
sex offenders,
what would it be for and what if there were a sex offender themselves that
doesn't exclude them or my parents?
Yeah.
I am afraid that there are innocent people on death row.
I think we can all agree.
Yup.
Yeah.
There's no denying that fuck is in the current could be more to or to be more
people.
The current count,
I believe ever since up President Carter is a hundred people have been found not
guilty due to basically witnesses lying DNA and are such things.
So a hundred people is not a small amount.
If one person is innocent,
that's enough for me to not trust the legal system.
Um,
and on top of that,
in terms of corruption,
racism,
all these kinds of things that affect our whole legal system,
I don't know why it's taboo to say that like,
yeah,
we need to admit that more and it's going to be okay.
Like let's admit it and move forward.
Can I get hugs?
She's good.
How's your mom doing?
Okay,
good job guys.
You guys,
this is Jason from jubilee.
We hope you enjoyed another wonderful episode of middle ground.
Let us know in the comments below what you thought as well as let us know if you
have any ideas for any new episodes.
As you tell,
we're listening to you guys and a lot of these are your suggestions,
so thank you.
Make sure you click here for more videos.
Click here to subscribe and we will see you as the next time.